hi everyone i want to read a piece for
you today that i wrote recently over
about a month
carefully assessing it with a number of
experts on foreign policy
it's called russia
versus ukraine
or civil war in the west
we are now several months into the
conflict with russia
i say we
because we are all pretending here in
the west that the real war is between
russia and ukraine but
not nod wink wink if we clandestinely in
some sense provide full support to
ukraine maybe the russians foolish and
backward as they are
won't notice and we can simultaneously
pretend that we aren't flirting with the
prospect of a long arduous and
inconceivably destructive war
i want to say at the outset
that i think what putin has done is
unconscionable god only knows what the
impact will be as all four of the
horsemen of the apocalypse are on the
march again
i also think that the collusion of the
leadership of the russian orthodox
church
is even more
unforgivable
be that as it may i also believe that
the attempt to deeply understand the
motive forces for this war
as it is very difficult to set things
right let alone avoid a similar future
catastrophe or even to stop this
conflict from spreading
in the absence of such understanding
i have spoken publicly on my youtube
channel and podcast with american
foreign policy expert frederick kagan
who was recommended to me by some of my
conservative associates in the u.s
people with extensive political
experience and simultaneously knowledge
about foreign policy kagan
is rather hawkish in his outlook and
reputation
and was criticized for this as i was for
hosting him in the social media comments
section accompanying my youtube channel
our joint episodes by the way have been
viewed or listened to by at least
three million people i'm saying this
just to provide evidence that these
discussions have had some impact in the
broad public sphere
dr kagan essentially put forward the
thesis
that vladimir putin
is a prototypical authoritarian
and that russia's foray into ukraine
might be properly viewed as an
expression of the imperial expansionism
that characterized the soviet union
so this is cold war round two
accompanying this view
is the interpretation of putin as a thug
in the hitlerian mold carrying a chip on
his shoulder interested primarily in
self-aggrandizement
and capitalizing on russian patriotism
and an associated populist appeal
to fortify his pretensions to empire and
desire for an unlimited extension of
personal power
this perspective which appears to
characterize what might be called the
western patriotic response to the
russian incursion has its very real
justifications
it appears part of uniting in response
to an enemy
part of justifying what is necessarily a
binary decision process are we at war or
not
if yes
then the question arises is the enemy
bad
by definition otherwise the war is
unpardonable and if we believe that to
be the case we will enter the fray
demoralized and compromise our chances
of victory
but one of the primary justifications
for a war perhaps is
that we have something to gain i see
that we have little to gain in the
current situation
and certainly
much we could lose russia
is a nuclear power
and we run the very real risk
of backing them into a corner
and that
bad as it is is only one of many of the
options for disaster
that currently face
us many people watching my exchange with
dr kagan suggested that i broaden my
understanding by reviewing the work of
dr john mearsheimer of the university of
chicago who offers an alternative
interpretation one that more
specifically highlights the faults of
the west
dr mearsheimer's remarkably prescient
2015
university of chicago lecture why is
ukraine the west's fault
available on youtube and now watched by
30 million people
an unheard of number for an academic
lecture
i was concerned that mirsheimer might be
a russian apologist in some relatively
simple manner although that does not
seem to be the case in a singularly
lucid one-hour presentation
mirsheimer explained that nato and
european union expansionism into ukraine
the invitation proffered to ukraine to
join the eu the formal statement of the
desirability of nato's extension into
ukraine has already
and will continue to pose an intolerable
threat to the russians
who view ukraine both as an integral
part of the broader russian sphere of
interest
and as a necessary buffer between the
europe that has invaded russia to
terrible effect in 1812 and 1941
and that is no more trustworthy to
russianize now
than previously mersheimer compared the
former element of that view to the u.s
monroe doctrine which makes the western
hemisphere sacrosanct with regards to
say the movement of soviet missiles to
cuba and the latter
to the stark realities of the difference
in the importance of ukraine to russia
crucial and to the west
irrelevant except for the transmission
of russian natural gas and any and all
current exploitation for the purposes of
shallow moral posturing
mirsheimer states starkly
and this explains a fair bit of putin's
potential motivation
that russia would rather see ukraine
destroyed
raised to the ground
than comfortably ensconced in the
western sphere of influence
and mirsheimer said that
not last month or last week in response
to the ukraine incursion
but seven years ago in 2015.
merchamer also claims that the ukraine
president yanukovych
deposed in 2014 in the aftermath of
widespread pro-eu protests was the clear
favorite and choice of the
russian-speaking ukrainians who
overwhelmingly occupy the southeastern
section of the country well zielinski
the current president and supporter of
all things western was and is supported
by the ukrainian speakers who live in
the northeast
add to that as well
the fact that the ukrainian-speaking
supported government has placed
increasingly draconian restrictions on
the language rights of the russian
speakers in the northwest
a fact all westerners balancing the
complexities of multiple languages in
their own countries should be
particularly sensitive to an
understanding of
all this to say that
putin and the russians
have their reasons for concern over the
situation in ukraine
we could reasonably add to these two
theories of the conflict some
observations
about the energy front
russia is a petro giant
providing almost 15 percent of the
world's supply of oil and natural gas
and is extremely dependent on that
single resource whose revenues make up
almost 50 percent of the state budget
and perhaps 30 percent of total gdp
almost half of the russian fossil fuels
exported make their way to europe
which has allowed itself
to become dangerously dependent on such
outside sources for one of its primary
necessities
not least because of its faux moral
stance on issues of
the environment
it's not so easy for the russians to get
their oil and gas to market partly
because the baomoth country is
remarkably landlocked in a practical
sense they've had to build extensive
pipelines to do so
the two of those that serve the european
market upon which the economy of russia
is fundamentally dependent pass through
what are now other countries
this is not convenient to say the least
for the russians
has caused no shortage of conflict
between them and ukraine specifically
and has certainly encouraged constant
russian interference in belarus
which is in some real sense a puppet
state of its larger partner
when the soviet empire collapsed
the huge oil fields around the caspian
sea suddenly found themselves in the
hands of the new countries of kazakhstan
azerbaijan uzbekistan and turkmenistan
after 1989 these resources attracted
major attention from western energy
companies
and untrammeled production from the new
countries posed a threat to russian
domination of the european energy market
this
has produced unending tension in the
region not least around azerbaijan which
has run its own pipelines to thirsty
western markets through georgia
invaded non-coincidentally by russia in
2008
turkey and albania thus partially
circumventing russian control
over petro export
the fact of this relative emerging
independence has also allowed azerbaijan
to move further away from the moscow's
centered sphere of influence and sets a
worrying example in the russian view to
other developing post-soviet countries
in the area
add to that
the fact that 80 of russia's oil and gas
exports once had to pass through ukraine
although this problem has been
remediated somewhat
and the stage was and is set for trouble
this became
particularly evident in 2005 with the
orange revolution and the rise of victor
yushenko's overtly pro-western ukrainian
regime
shortly thereafter the russians demanded
that ukraine turn over ownership of the
pipeline system traversing that country
to them
this request
was refused
in response and during the winter the
russians briefly turned off the taps
supplying ukraine with the petro
resources upon which that country was
also acutely dependent
it is also the case that ukraine has
immense and relatively recently
discovered circa 2010
petrol resources of its own
particularly around the caspian sea and
in the northeast
enough natural gas for example so that
it could have become a major supplier of
that resource to europe and thereby pose
a threat to european reliance on russian
resources
ukraine also possesses
although perhaps not after the current
war immense storage capacity for petrol
resources another asset that could limit
the influence that russia can exert over
its european customers by providing a
buffer against any suddenly imposed
limitation of supply
in the last decade ukraine has been
actively pursuing agreements with
exxonmobil shell and chevron to develop
and export their new resources
the 2014 pro-western revolution in
ukraine
toppling what was then the pro-russian
government there
did little
to set russian mines at ease
the consequent invasion of crimea
placed a substantial proportion of the
new ukraine petra reserves in russian
hands
the later invasion of the donbass region
in the aforementioned northeast
punitively to support pro-russian
separatists there
was perhaps motivated
by analogous reasons
so that's three hypothetical reasons for
russia and ukraine
first
putin the imperialist soviet-era
hitlerian thug
second
russia threatened by careless and
provocative western expansionism into a
country we really don't care about
except when our unearned moral virtue is
challenged but which is key to russian
identity and security
third
russian concern about maintaining its
primarily petrol-funded economy
particularly in relation to the european
market
but even three reasons are not enough to
account for the fact of this war
and its emergence here and now
there's a fourth
precisely germane to why i entitled this
essay
civil war in the west
in the west no not in the russian empire
a few weeks ago one of my viewers or
readers or listeners sent me a copy of
the great russian novelist dostoevsky's
a writer's diary
dostoevsky regarded a writer's diary
twice the length in its entirety of his
longer works of fiction as his
preeminent achievement it's a hybrid
work which he began publishing as a
series of columns in a conservative
weekly journal called the citizen
it is the work of the accomplished
journalist the great russian author was
in daring combination with the works of
fiction which he employed parable-like
to buttress his intellectual and more
political points
in it dostoevsky outlined his view of
his homeland's destiny which he saw as
crucially inseparable from russia's role
in christendom
that archaic notion russia is neither
catholic nor protestant but orthodox in
its religious matters
and that fact remains of serious
importance in my opinion
to a proper understanding of the
terrible situation we in the west
including russia now find ourselves in
dostoevsky concerned himself with a
philosophical or
more profoundly
theological issue
the crisis of meaning
in the west
addressing an issue that has become of
key psychological and social importance
again
today his
crime and punishment
is a psychological investigation
focusing on questions of right and wrong
or good and evil
are human beings
devoid of religious presuppositions
now
free
to make their own choices
even matters of murder
in the brothers karamazov
dostoevsky asks
is everything permitted
now that god is dead
in the devils
also known as the possessed he asks
what forms might belief take and and to
what end when the strictures of
traditional belief are burst asunder
what dread demons might take the place
of the displaced yahwah
dostoevsky fervently believed in the
necessity of a revival of christianity
in the more psychological sense central
to the orthodox doctrine of theosis the
transformative process whose aim is
individual likeness to our union with
god
and he believed that the russians would
and would need to play a central role in
that revival
everyone listening to
or watching or reading this might be
thinking what could such arcane things
possibly have to do with the
practicalities of the current war
but that is an indication of our
superficiality and ignorance here in the
west
and not with the relevance of such
things
to the state of the world
when alexander solzhenitsyn wrote the
gulag archipelago the book that shook
the foundations of the cold war era
world he suggested like dostoyevsky
that it would be necessary for the
russians to return to the path of
incremental organic development that had
been manifesting itself prior to the
revolutionary disruptions of the
communist catastrophe
that meant
a return to orthodox belief
there's every sign of a revival of
christianity in russia including a
veritable storm of church building and
cathedral construction
putin himself
is in principle a practicing christian
and it appears
that he has been strongly influenced by
such ideas
the degree to which putin's worldview
and actions are shaped by his professed
christianity
is a topic subject to appropriate debate
but the same can be said about the views
and actions of all who adopt or claim to
adopt a faith i certainly feel somewhat
more comfortable knowing that putin
regards himself however indeterminately
as subordinate to something beyond
himself
as the alternative is dreadful to
contemplate
that would be the absolute moral
presumption of someone such as stalin
regardless of the depth or genuineness
of his belief however it is beyond
dispute that the russian leader
frequently speaks of his country's role
as a bulwark against the moral decadence
of the west
and that he speaks in philosophical and
theological terms to a degree
unthinkable in a western leader all of
whom tend towards a condescension in
such matters
that has reached its apotheosis in
canada's justin trudeau new zealand's
jacinda arden and u.s vice president
kamala harris
he also collaborates in his thinking
with a genuine philosopher alexander
dugan
you can say
or think
what you want about dugan
as a philosopher but the fact remains
that such thinking has exercised
a deep influence on putin and russia
putin
regards the current west as decadent
to the point of absolute
untrustworthiness particularly on the
cultural and religious front
he is driven by economic and political
necessity to trade with us and us with
him so that russia can be supplied by
much needed hard western currency and
europe in particular with fossil fuel
but putin
constantly tells his people
that he sees us falling far too far
under the sway of ideas very similar to
those that produce the revolutionary
frenzy of the communist movement
and detailed so presciently by
dostoevsky in the devils and analyzed
for their catastrophic consequence so
carefully by solzhenitsyn
and whether he believes this or not
and i believe he does
he is certainly able and willing to use
the story of our degeneration
to make his people wary of us
and to convince them of the necessity of
his leadership and to unite them
in supporting his actions in ukraine
and something akin to this can be said
of the attraction that hungarian prime
minister victor orban holds for the
hungarians
and the polish president for the polls
le pen makes a similar appeal in france
and are we degenerate
in a profoundly threatening manner
i think the answer to that may well be
yes
the idea that we are ensconced in a
culture war has become a rhetorical
commonplace
how serious is that war
is it serious enough to increase the
probability that russia
say
will be motivated to invade and
potentially incapacitate ukraine merely
to keep the pathological west out of
that country which is a key part of the
historically russian sphere of influence
to answer that question
i'll turn to the analysis of a recent
sequence of significant events in the
u.s with broader ramifications for the
development of political thought in the
west as such
when
the biden administration
began the process of identifying a new
supreme court justice a singular message
was initially trumpeted
it is time for a black woman
to take her place in the highest
tribunal in the land
i
thought this was a terrible strategic
error speaking as someone who would
rather see the democrat sane
then deluded
why not first announce the search
for the most credible candidate
and then report the discovery of the
candidate with ethically fortuitous sex
and genetic
structure why wouldn't that sequence
make the most sense from within the
democrat fortress itself the fact of
qualification made primary and the
secondary providence that such
qualification could be provided by
someone who would also simultaneously
serve as a beacon to the striving
minorities and underprivileged but no
sex and race were first
this begs the question
does qualification even matter
now
technically speaking
announcing a priory restriction of the
candidacy
to women
and black
means the restriction of the potential
pool of candidates by 50 percent the
approximate relative prevalence of women
versus men
and then that half
by initial 87 percent as black citizens
of the us constitute 13 of the
population
so that is an a priori restriction of
the probability of picking the most
competent candidate by 100
minus 0.5 times 0.13
equals
93.5 percent
that's a tremendous restriction that
means that it is so important to pick a
black woman not my words
that 18 out of 20 potentially qualified
contenders will be dismissed
out of the gate
and that restriction which is
unwarranted except for the direst of
reasons in my estimation given the
crucial importance of the position is an
error
in addition to the error of putting the
cart before the horse in the first place
this is particularly true because the
relationship between competence and
performance is non-linear
an excellent candidate for a given job
is not merely slightly better than a
very good candidate but often
incomparably better the difference
between someone at the 99th percentile
and the 99.9 percentile in terms of
competence is the difference between the
best person out of a hundred
and the best person
out of a thousand
this is a difference so big that the
consequences can be and have been world
changing a difference that is
particularly important when the position
in question is of crucial significance
i tweeted out something in this regard
and was immediately uprated by some of
my intelligent capable and admirable
democrat friends people with no small
influence in washington they said you
are correct in a technical sense but you
radically underestimate the degree to
which such appointments have been made
for political reasons in the past
reasons that also reduce the pool of
potential candidates to an arguably
equal degree a priori but which weren't
linked so obviously to race and sex you
are inflaming racial tensions by
objecting and that's not helpful
etc
furthermore the candidate in question
does meet or exceed threshold for
acceptability on grounds of pure
qualification and the advantage of her
minority status is a genuine and
defensible mark in her favor
given
the historical context
now i take the people who told me this
seriously
and i backed off in some sense i thought
okay i'll give you all that
i still think it was utterly foolish and
pandering of the worst and most
unforgivable sort to announce the
necessity of a black woman first
but your criticisms of previous
appointments may be on point
i also think that the probability that
she was the most qualified candidate is
close to nil
but she did seem arguably acceptably
credible given the unreliability of
previous nominations
and i think that most people who think
like me including those directly
involved in the hearings which led to
her eventual qualification felt the same
way she was certainly not subject to the
same roasting over a slow fire that
characterized the hearings for the
previous republican nominee kavanaugh
but it remains true that sex and race
trumped qualification
and a moral case was made for that
decision
and that in and of itself does not
provide
indication of
western
derangement
but
but
when the self-same candidate was asked
directly in an interview
during the confirmation process
the very straightforward question
what is a woman which granted was a
gotcha question which only goes to show
the severity of our current level of
derangement and so is no excuse for
failure to answer
she said
i'm not a biologist
that is not a good answer
now she well knew that the question was
a setup as did the interview who posed
it she knew as did the interviewer that
she would be pilloried no matter how she
answered it
in consequence she evaded the issue
entirely
but in a manner specifically designed
not to antagonize the appalling radical
left and i'm even willing to grant her
the moral right to do that given that no
one wants to be pilloried and that no
one should be subject to mobbing merely
because they give an answer to a
question the answer to which is evident
to anyone who maintains an iota of
sanity and integrity
but
here's where i'm not willing to go
even given that
as the confirmation process reached its
conclusion
we were enjoined by the biden
administration and the woke allies it
panders too shamefully and unceasingly
to celebrate the positioning of the
desired nominee
on the basis
of the initial call
for her nomination
that is on the basis of her sex and race
at precisely the same time that we were
also enjoined
to remain entirely dubious again on
moral grounds that any such category as
sex
even validly existed
there is a principle
the principle of non-contradiction
acceptance of which in principle
serves as one of the foundations
for the practice of discourse itself
that principle is the assertion that it
is fundamentally unreasonable
irredeemably irrational to claim
that a
and not a
are identical
why
well because if you can claim that a
thing is what it is and what it is not
simultaneously
then you can claim anything whatsoever
and if you can claim anything whatsoever
as true
then it is impossible to talk with you
you
have departed from the sphere of reason
and reasonable discourse you have
departed from the realm of the rational
this means
that you have become deranged
this means that you have become
degenerate
this means that all who fail to call you
on your deranged degeneration
have become rowers
on the same
doomed boat
this means that you and all those who do
not call you out
have become insane
this is against a well-established
background of such insistence upon the
mandatory acceptance of contradiction
in our society
all sexual proclivities and desires no
matter how rare dangerous or socially
disruptive are not to be merely
tolerated
but must be
celebrated pride month outright or else
and regarded as hedonically desirable
and absolutely harmless
but sex is simultaneously so dangerous
that every such interaction to take a
single example between young men and
women on campus
is to be regarded as deeply and
patriarchally exploitative in its
intrinsic nature tantamount even if
voluntary to rape as andrea dworkin and
catherine mckinnon have insisted and
therefore necessarily preceded by the
establishment of explicit consent
formulated to a degree of precision that
would hold in court under adversarial
challenge
in our society furthermore
the difference between men and women
is held to be purely cultural even at
the level of physiology there are no
markers even genital that allow for the
reliable discrimination of infant boys
from girls
while whatever differences may still be
held to remain are trivial biologically
negligible in the impact of their
existence on destiny and easily properly
and necessarily modifiable culturally
but so vitally and singly and crucially
important to identity and mental health
alike that misgendering is a crime
and that surgical intervention on minors
is a positive good not to be questioned
under punishment by law as an
intervention in the increasingly common
case of childhood gender dysphoria
such contradictions
do not bother the radicals and they are
far more radical than they even know who
wish fervently to destabilize our
society to end capitalism to destroy the
free market to bring down the oppression
of the enlightenment to undermine and
destroy the judeo-christian or even
abrahamic axioms that undergird our
culture
and to dance in the resultant flames
with glee
while doing so
and if you don't think these ideas are
under assault in some serious way you
are blind and willfully so and heading
for a pit
truly
and
are not
the russians
and the hungarians and the poles and the
indians to a lesser degree
watching and thinking
those people have gone out of their
minds
and
we have
to say it again clearly
the culture war in the west is real
and culture is losing
and russia
is part of the west
and the culture war
is now truly part
of why we have a
war and it's a real war
and it is certainly the case that we do
not therefore have all the moral high
ground
for some part of the reasons that
mirsheimer details and for these reasons
of insanity
in fact how much of it we have at all
is something rightly subject to the most
serious debate
and i'm saying this as someone who also
takes the advice of someone like
frederick kagan seriously
thus the russians think in some
combination of convenient for them
and accuracy in relationship to us on
top of their imperialist ambitions and
their nationalistic populism and the
potential thuggery of their leader all
that taken into account
those westerners are so out of their
mind
possessed by the very ideas that
destroyed us for a century and didn't
they
that we simply cannot trust them
those westerners are so out of their
mind
that a devastated but neutral ukraine
is preferable
to a functional bordering state aligned
with the us and europe
those westerners
are so out of their mind
it will push the world to the brink of a
nuclear war
and potentially beyond
to keep them off our doorstep
because we've been there before
and we're not going back
and that is exactly what putin tells his
people
and they believe it
and in some sense therefore it doesn't
even matter if putin believes it
although i believe he does along with
whatever else he might believe in
relationship to personal ambition and
self-aggrandizement and the willingness
to aggress and the desirability of
resurgent russian empire and so the
russians believe that they have a moral
duty and that they have the highest
moral duty to oppose the degenerate
ideas philosophy
theology of the west
and there's something about that
that is not wrong
and that is why the incursion of russia
into ukraine is
more truly
a civil war
in the west
i should also point out
it is not only the russians who object
to the nightmare of compassionate
authoritarianism that increasingly
possesses the west all the eastern
european countries whose populations
groaned under the stalinist burden are
watching the resurgence of these
demented ideas among their erstwhile
enlightened allies with stunned
disbelief
romanians estonians hungarians albanians
all those countries
characterized by a traumatic wisdom
all extremely unhappy
that those who should know better and
who have built their economic strength
and base their freedom on ideas that
promote equality of opportunity but
denounce enforced equity or equality of
outcome kowtow
to the resentful full moralistic
opportunistic anarchic narcissists of
the radical left
if our g7 leaders had one iota sense in
my opinion they would be doing nothing
right now but dispensing with the too
convenient identification of putin with
hitler or stellan and focusing with
single-minded intensity on determining
exactly what the russians would accept
as a minimum precondition for peace
have we been paying attention to what
putin's men have been saying about the
uk
to take a single example
a russian tv host recently boasted
that a single ceremony missile
would be sufficient to destroy britain
once and for all
perhaps the declaration of ukraine has a
neutral state for a minimum period of 20
years
perhaps a new election in ukraine
subject to ratification by joint russian
western observers perhaps a pledge on
the part of the west to not offer to
ukraine any membership in nato or the eu
that is either not simultaneously
offered to russia or moving forward on
terms acceptable to russia and if not
any of these offerings
and i may be dreadfully naive for
reasons i do not know about such matters
and therefore wrong in my specific
suggestions
then something else that will bring
peace
and the sooner the better the russians
are a nuclear power the russians have a
sphere of influence the russians have
already integrated into the world
economy
in a manner that cannot be compromised
without devastating global consequences
and
all protestations to the contrary
none of us give a damn about ukraine
and never have
remember the hallmador
do you even know what it was
well for the russians ukraine is akin in
some important sense to russia itself
even more so than the monroe doctrine
western hemisphere is the us
i'm not saying that ukraine is part of
russia or that the ukrainians agree with
the russians
but our current concern is very
self-aggrandizing
and unreliable
and this is particularly true given that
we in the west that opposes russia
have very much to lose in this battle we
have not yet woken up fully
to what that loss
will look like
allow me therefore to prognosticate both
pessimistically
and worse
realistically
i believe that all of the following
consequences
are already inevitable
first
skyrocketing energy prices i firmly
expect oil prices
to hit 300 a barrel or worse in the
upcoming year or two perhaps i am wrong
in such a prognostication
but the russians still have control of
some very important taps
and will be hard-pressed not to employ
that strategic advantage as their
position in ukraine and on the world
stage deteriorates as it inevitably must
these higher energy prices will of
course
hurt the world's poor and developing
countries hardest
as well as those who in the west must
rely on low wages or fixed incomes
the idiot environmental policies that we
insist on pursuing
not least in justin trudeau's
increasingly dysfunctional canada are
exacerbating this problem unforgivably
and it has become obvious in countries
such as the uk and germany
that the hypothetically compassionate
and working class positive green types
and their ilk
are perfectly willing
to sacrifice
today's actual pour to the
hypothetically thriving poor of their
imaginary future utopia
second
severe food shortages
or even famine
for a minimum of 150 million people
and substantial pressure on the price of
basic necessities even in the developed
countries as for example ukraine alone
produces 20 percent of the world's
high-grade wheat and will soon be unable
to ship that food
or
to store
what will be this year's much diminished
crop
these shortages and worse
will hit hard as early as the fall of
2022.
add to this problem
a looming scarcity of fertilizer
30 percent produced by ukraine and
russia which will affect harvests and
prices worldwide
and we have the makings of a
humanitarian disaster on a scale not
experienced
since the 1960s
third
mass migration
the country's most affected by the
aforementioned food shortage
will be precisely those north african
and middle eastern nations from which
the last mass migration that so stressed
europe to say nothing of the immigrants
themselves
expect immense mass movements of
desperate people by november of 2022
and all the exacerbation
of religious and nationalist tension and
internal polarization along political
fracture lines that accompanies a sudden
and uncontrollable influx of people
fourth
and most immediately if the build-up of
nato forces continues and they are in
fact then moved into battle position
a real likelihood of the use of tactical
nuclear weapons on the russian side to
deal with that threat
three hundred thousand have been very
recently put on high readiness prepared
for immediate deployment as opposed to
the 40 000 currently available for rapid
reaction
all this appears to be based on the
assumption
that the russians will back down
if threatened enough
this didn't work for the germans with
regards to britain in the days of the
blitz why would we underestimate
the determination of the russians they
have seen hardships that those of us in
the west can thankfully not even imagine
we will not cow them into submission
as they will not prove willing to lose
and it's not as though the economic
sanctions have been working or have been
without major collateral damage on a
scale yet to be seen the ruble is doing
just fine and oil prices are not
finished escalating all this is enabling
putin to establish firm trading partners
for his valuable commodities outside the
direct western sphere of influence and
the other opec partners are not going to
just turn on the taps
which are already putting forth at full
volume and the west will have neither
the will nor the ability to scale up
domestic energy production given our
current state of ideological paralysis
we cannot do
without the russians on our side here in
the rest of the western world
the chinese communists loom too
remember them we haven't even discussed
this side of the problem and the ccp
system is antithetical to ours in every
manner despite the admiration expressed
for this system
by some of the most short-sighted of the
west's leaders
that's you again canadian prime minister
justin trudeau
and the chinese are subtle and patient
in a manner we no longer understand and
we are shallow and foolish and
short-sighted and narcissistic and
ungrateful
our wealth
our unearned birthright to a great
degree deludes us into believing in our
competence and moral superiority
but the fact that you're born into
wealth does not indicate that you are
able upright and responsible
i cannot see
how we can defeat
the russians
in any real sense
because they will not allow themselves
to lose
because the consequences even of an
overwhelming military victory for our
side will be internationally disastrous
and finally because the quarrel that
lies at one part of the bottom of this
war will not disappear at all and may
even worsen if the russians somehow lose
with regard to that final point the war
of ideas that has given rise to the
current real war will continue its
destructive and nihilistic progress even
if the russians capitulate and agree to
the re-establishment of the pre-invasion
boundaries
it is not obvious that well that war of
ideas continues that the russians will
even allow a prosperous ukraine allied
more closely with the west on their
border
and it's wishful thinking to imagine
that this war will end with the
ignominious departure of a putin in
disgrace
not only is he popular
but he is arguably much less terrible
than almost any leader that has preceded
him for a century in russia that may be
damning with faint praise
but it's something necessary to
understand in relationship to the
promulgation of any naive and foolish
optimism
this is a war that cannot be run in the
most fundamental sense by the mere
defeat of russia
the civil war in the west can only be
won on the intellectual or even the
spiritual front and the victory will be
defeat of the radical ideas of marxist
inheritance that are currently
destabilizing our societies russia and
ukraine included
it is the job of classic liberals
small c conservatives and more
importantly adherence to the abrahamic
traditions to bring about that defeat in
the realm of ideas
where the true battles most truly rage
in the meantime
instead
we fight our petty battles in the west
worrying about our privilege while
enjoying it fully
obsessing about the woke triumvirate of
diversity inclusivity and equity
wallowing in the immature narcissism of
our solipsistic identity debates whiling
the time away
as something truly terrible comes for us
down the pipes
we are at great risk of destabilizing
the amazing interdependent world
prosperity that is so unlikely was so
difficult to attain and which we have
enjoyed for only a few short decades and
we are taking that risk so blindly and
willfully so so stupidly so childishly
and so pridefully
the hunger of millions will soon be upon
us and that is not all
can we not get our priorities right and
step back from that precipice
with the proper vision and aim
all
could have all that is needed
perhaps even all that is wanted
instead
we could have hell
just as we've had it before
do we really need to go there again
i might also point out
if all of this has not been enough
that this war may be in some real sense
another one of the myriad unintended
consequences of the idiot invasive and
authoritarian covid lockdown
when was the last time that a western
leader spent some time
face to face
with putin
not by zoom
not by skype
in the same room
breathing the same air communicating
directly with all available verbal and
crucially important nonverbal channels
fully functioning
sharing a meal or an anecdote or a drink
engaging in all of those social
interactions of inarticulable complexity
aimed at establishing a relationship
overcoming inevitable distrust at a
personal level
has it been
several years
in any real sense
has that simply been too long
will this be another severe consequence
of our rush
to assume that we can virtualize the
real without unforeseen loss
perhaps i might end this litany of
warnings and woe
with a story
and not one that i think
will improve anyone's mood
as has become somewhat widely known
putin had an encounter with an angry and
desperate rodent when he was young
quote there on that stair landing i got
a quick and lasting lesson in the
meaning of the word
cornered
there were hordes of rats in the front
entryway my friends and i used to chase
them around with sticks once i spotted a
huge rat and pursued it down the hall
until i drove it
into a corner
it had nowhere to run
suddenly it lashed around
and threw itself at me
i was surprised and frightened now the
rat was chasing me
it jumped across the landing and down
the stairs luckily i was a little faster
and i managed to slam the door
on its nose
now
putin is not a rat
and we are not children tormenting rats
with sticks
or at least we shouldn't be
i spoke recently with the former
albanian minister of foreign affairs and
he told me
that there are western leaders who hold
the view that russia's president needs
to be humiliated so that he will learn
his lesson
here's a lesson
from the benighted vengeful versailles
treaty designed to humiliate and [ __ ]
the germans in the aftermath of the
brutalities of world war one
don't plant the seeds that will blossom
into the next war
putin will not be around in 10 years or
so
but russia
will remain
this isn't
or shouldn't be
personal
although the relationships that might
bring peace need to be and let's not
corner the explosive bear that is russia
no mere contemptible rat or aim at a
high school like humiliation of its
leader and therefore its people no
matter how misguided we may believe they
presently are we need to find a way out
of this awful mess this terrible tar
baby before it engulfs us all
and it needs to be the top priority of
those who purport to lead and guide us
here in the west